thank you for joining us i'm john
langler this afternoon clark county
school superintendent dr jesus jarrah is
out of a job last night he was pushed
out by the school board in a tight 4-3
vote the looming question today what
happens next for the nation's fifth
largest school district hector mejia is
joining us live here in studio with i
guess some of the questions and
hopefully some answers hector yeah well
this afternoon we have more questions
than answers it is nevada day so school
district offices are closed regardless
we reached out to ccsd but again no
answers during thursday's heated ccsd
board meeting the clark county education
association also known as the teachers
union spoke out when will the focus be
on student achievement ccea president
marie nices criticized the move by some
board members to terminate dr jesus
jarrah's contract while i have openly
criticized dr jarrah and the school
district's handling of the return to
in-person instruction just as educators
demand fair and objective evaluations
your single employee should have that
same process
the superintendent should be evaluated
on his performance which should have a
high standard and be transparent and
public at the december 9th board meeting
dr jarro was hired in 2018 with an
annual salary of three hundred twenty
thousand dollars in may of twenty twenty
one trustees had voted to extend his
contract hoping he would continue as
superintendent until twenty twenty three
we're working for clarity from ccsd on a
couple of questions is there a timeline
for what happens next what's the process
moving forward is there an interim
superintendent lined up and will ccsd
pay the remainder of jarrah's contract
i also reached out to the nevada
department of education to get some
questions answered by the state
superintendent but the response i got
was quote nde does not comment on local
matters hector mejia live local now
hector thank you very much we'll have
much more on this of course on eight
news now at 4 5 and 6. dr jarrow read
this statement on your screen at the
board meeting following the decision
quote while some board members while
some members of this board seek to
continue and try to run the operations
of this school district and micromanage
me and undermine staff
i have been dedicated to protecting
staff from an overreach and interference
again we have more of that on
eightnewsnow.com